y llegó el momento hablar de economía
acá en france 24 para ello me acompaña
en el estudio daniel hablando con
daniela buena noche bienvenida los
cárteles del crimen latinoamericanos
recurren a las cripto monedas para el
lavado de dinero vamos buenas noches
después es mucho lo que han alertado las
autoridades de todo el mundo y nosotros
también sobre el uso de las cripto
monedas ya que no sólo una divisa
legalmente reconocida ni regulada y
mucho menos vigilada
ahora las autoridades de estados unidos
y méjico les están siguiendo el rastro
dicen que el uso del bitcoin para lavar
dinero está aumentando particularmente
entre bandas como el cártel jalisco
nueva generación y el cártel de sinaloa
del chapo guzmán según la secretaria de
hacienda de méxico los narcotraficantes
compran pequeñas cantidades de bitcoins
en línea para pagar a sus colaboradores
en todo el mundo sin dejar huella alguna
y es que este es un sistema en el que
los usuarios son prácticamente anónimos
en méxico ya hay una ley que obliga a
las plataformas de comercio con cripto
monedas
transferencias de más de dos mil
ochocientos dólares pero aunque ya ha
habido éxito en algunas capturas sigue
siendo muy difícil llevar un control
daniela y en bolivia también grabarán
las fortunas de los más ricos ya pasó en
argentina y en chile se alcanzó a
discutir pero no ha prosperado todavía
en colombia existe hace mucho tiempo el
turno ahora es para bolivia la cámara de
diputados que es controlada por el
oficialismo aprobó y envió al senado un
proyecto de ley para cobrar un impuesto
anual y permanente a las fortunas
individuales que superen los 43 millones
de dólares entre más sea la riqueza
mayor sería el impuesto si está entre 30
y 40 millones de pesos bolivianos es
decir de 43 a 57 millones de dólares
pagarían unos 21.500 dólares y si supera
ese umbral y se va a los 50 millones
el gravamen es cuatro veces mayor el
gobierno estima recaudar unos 15
millones de dólares de alrededor de 150
contribuyentes también se aprobó otra
iniciativa raúl la de devolver un 5 por
ciento de la
compras facturadas a personas con
ingresos menores a 1.300 dólares
mensuales
así es angeli la comisión europea avanza
de esta semana con una agenda muy
apretada bastante apretada raúl las
caras largas están por el lado del break
city con cada vez menos esperanzas de un
acuerdo comercial el domingo se anuncia
una decisión pero londres ya anticipa
que será muy difícil coincidir en algo
pero si hay motivo para celebrar en lo
que a la economía comunitaria se refiere
hungría y polonia por fin levantaron el
veto que le habían impuesto al
presupuesto del bloque en los próximos
seis años y a un fondo de recuperación
postpandemia bosch por 2,1 millones de
dólares ellos suponían porque las ayudas
estaban sujetas al cumplimiento del
estado de derecho y estos dos países no
tienen muy buena antecedentes en este
sentido quien mejor lo resumió fue el
primer ministro húngaro dijo no nos
podemos tomar todavía el champán pero lo
podemos ir enfriando
hay propuestas sobre la mesa que muchos
estados miembros como nosotros los
húngaros no nos gustarán esta acción la
gestión de la migración o las medidas
anti familia planeadas por bruselas así
que tenemos mucho trabajo por zelanda
daniela y esta fue una semana de
estrenos en wall street si muy temprano
en la semana empezó el agua que comenzó
a cotizarse en el mercado de commodities
de la bolsa de nueva york y del lado
empresarial este jueves empezó a cotizar
el bien vi que captó 3700 millones de
dólares en lo que fue la salida a bolsa
más grande de este año el precio de sus
acciones como vemos se duplicó en
cuestión de horas otro que debutó en
wall street eso es doble das una
aplicación de comida a domicilio que el
miércoles logró un ascenso del 86 por
ciento en su salida a bolsa así de
indicadores nos quedamos en wall street
porque eeuu de cerró mixto en una sesión
bastante plana que sólo animó el
eufórico debut de bien
en europa las bolsas también cerraron
dispares en medio de previsiones
negativas del banco central europeo y en
latinoamérica buenos avances en las
plazas bursátiles de tres de las
principales economías y para finalizar
que nos trae como cifra el día 853.000 a
de estas cifras se dispararon en la
última semana las solicitudes de
subsidio por desempleo en eeuu es la
primera vez en tres meses que alcanza
esta cifra
daniela como siempre muchísimas gracias
por toda la información económica de
ustedes también gracias y continúe con
nosotros
y